Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速向大家透露一件目前正在进行的激动人心的事。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都对你适用。丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战赛，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发一条简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这期节目成为你的指南吧。欢迎收听“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。
Thank you so much as ever for joining me. I am absolutely delighted that so many of you are finding this content useful. We very recently celebrated our 5,000th download, which means that 5,000 of the episodes have been listened to. And I am thrilled with that. You know, we launched Christmas Eve 2021. And so it's been four months, so 5000 downloads in four months for our really pretty niche market is just wonderful. So thank you again. If you do like what we do with this podcast, then please do take a moment just to drop in to the podcast app on Apple and rate it, rate the podcast. And you can do that by finding the podcast, the Aspiring Psychologist podcast in the podcast Apple app, scrolling to the bottom and then right below the trailer, right to the bottom,
非常感谢大家一如既往地陪伴我。我真的非常高兴有这么多人发现这些内容很有用。我们最近刚刚庆祝了第五千次下载，这意味着我们的节目已经被收听了 5000 次。我对此感到兴奋不已。你知道，我们是在 2021 年平安夜开播的，所以到现在是四个月，在我们的这个相对小众的市场里，四个月达到 5000 次下载真的是太棒了。所以再次感谢大家。如果你确实喜欢我们在本播客中做的事情，请花一点时间打开苹果播客应用程序并给它打个分，给播客评个分。你可以通过在苹果播客应用中找到“有志心理学家播客”，滚动到最底部，就在预告片正下方，一直拉到最底部，
you will find just where you can click on the stars to rate it. That will take you like, you know, 10 seconds. If you've got a few more moments, I would be thrilled if you left us a review as well, because reviews and ratings help us demonstrate that other people might also find it useful. If you'd like to go one better, and you'd like to leave us an audio testimonial to be used within the podcast for either the podcast itself, the book or the Aspiring Psychologist membership, I would be absolutely thrilled to have your voice on the podcast and you can be anonymous or you can use your name too. With that in mind we are
你会发现你可以点击星星进行评分的地方。这大概只需要你花上10秒钟。如果你还有多一点时间，如果你能顺便给我们留下评论，我会更加高兴，因为评论和评分有助于我们向世人证明，其他人也可能会觉得它很有用。如果你想做得更好，并且愿意留下语音评价以便在播客中使用——无论是针对播客本身、图书还是“有志心理学家会员计划”，我都会非常高兴能在播客中听到你的声音，你可以选择匿名，也可以使用你的真名。带着这个想法，我们
still recruiting people to write for the Aspiring Psychologist Collective and if you would like to write with your actual name that's okay, if you'd like us to give you a pseudonym that is also okay. You can find details of all of this stuff by heading to my Linktree account, which is probably most easily found by clicking on the show notes. But if you do follow me on any of my social media, then you can also click the link in my bio is also my Linktree. So, yeah, find me that way. But do come and connect. I love to help you celebrate on social media when you have significant milestones in your career, like new jobs, you know, graduating and just doing nice stuff in your life. So come and connect, come and follow me, interact with my content, and let's get to know each other better because that helps me know what you want me to create for you in this podcast too. I am very excited to bring to you today Dr. Lucy Johnston she is someone that when I was an aspiring psychologist I really looked up to
仍在招募人员为《有志心理学家集体》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）撰稿，如果你想用真名撰稿是可以的，如果你希望我们给你起个笔名也是可以的。你可以在我的 Linktree 账号中找到所有这些内容的详细信息，点击节目文案（show notes）通常是最容易找到的。但如果你在我的任何社交媒体上关注了我，你也可以点击我个人简介（bio）里的链接，那也是我的 Linktree。所以，是的，通过这种方式找到我。不过快来和我交流吧。当你在职业生涯中取得重要里程碑时，比如找到新工作、毕业以及生活中发生的美好事情，我都很乐意在社交媒体上帮您庆祝。所以快来与我建立联系，关注我，与我的内容互动，让我们更好地了解彼此，因为这能让我知道你们希望我在这档播客中为你创造什么样的内容。我非常高兴能向大家介绍今天的嘉宾露西·约翰逊博士（Dr. Lucy Johnston），她是我在立志成为心理学家时非常仰慕的人，
and was inspired by her work and so I honestly couldn't believe it when I reached out to her to invite her along to speak to us on the podcast and she was so happy to take part so I hope you'll find this useful her work is incredibly valid incredibly important to you as aspiring psychologists and even qualified psychologists too so I hope you'll find this a really inspiring really thought-provoking episode and as ever I would love any feedback or thoughts that you've got on it. Enjoy and I will catch you on the other side. So we are welcoming along Dr Lucy Johnston to us with the podcast today. Welcome along Lucy. Thank you, thank you for asking me. Oh thank you for saying yes. I feel like your work has been so important to me as an aspiring
并且深受她工作的启发。所以当我联系她邀请她来播客做客时，我简直不敢相信她如此乐意参与。所以我希望你们会觉得这期节目很有用，她的工作对于你们这些有志心理学家甚至是已经取得资质的心理学家来说，都具有难以置信的价值和极其重要的意义。所以我希望你们会觉得这是一期非常鼓舞人心、引人深思的节目，和往常一样，我非常期待听到你们对这期节目的任何反馈或想法。尽情享受吧，我们节目后半部分见。那么今天我们迎来了露西·约翰逊博士做客播客。欢迎你，露西。谢谢你，谢谢你邀请我。哦，谢谢你答应我。我觉得你的工作对我的影响太重大了，无论是作为一个有志于成为
psychologist, a trainee psychologist and a qualified psychologist as well. Good, I'm glad to hear that. Could you tell us a little bit about you and your work? Well, I've been a psychologist, a clinical psychologist for a very long time. I've always worked in adult mental health settings and I've worked partly in clinical settings but I've partly worked in training and for a while I worked at one of the local universities in Bristol so it's been quite a mixed career. I actually gave up clinical work at the end of 2016 and I'm currently describing myself as self-employed. I do writing and training. So this is a new and unexpected part of my career, in fact.
心理学家的学员，还是一个实习心理学家，以及后来的注册心理学家。很好，很高兴听到你这么说。你能跟我们简单聊聊你和你的工作吗？好的，我从事心理学家、临床心理学家已经有很长一段时间了。我一直在成人心理健康领域工作，一部分时间在临床环境中工作，但也有一部分时间从事培训工作，我曾在布里斯托尔的一所当地大学工作过一段时间，所以我的职业生涯经历相当丰富。我在 2016 年年底实际上放弃了临床工作，目前我称自己为自由职业者。我从事写作和培训工作。事实上，这是我职业生涯中崭新且意想不到的一部分。
And the same themes have followed me throughout my work, really, which is thinking about alternatives to the diagnostic model of distress. And everything I've written or done has been a variation on that theme. Brilliant and yeah you first crossed my path when I was trying to get interviews on clinical training and talking about formulation. Could you tell us a little bit about yours and Rudy Dallas's book on formulation how that came to be? Okay so as we know formulation is a core skill of clinical psychologists um and i had always used it i was trained to use formulation as all psychologists are i hadn't think i probably hadn't thought a huge amount about the subject until i um took a post on a clinical psychology doctorate myself and then I was in a position of training other people in
而且，贯穿我整个工作生涯的主题其实都是一样的，那就是思考关于心理痛苦诊断模型的替代方案。我写过或做过的一切都是围绕这个主题的各种变体。太棒了。是的，你最初进入我的视线，是在我试图通过临床培训面试并谈论个案概念化（formulation）的时候。你能跟我们聊聊你和鲁迪·达拉斯（Rudy Dallos）合著的那本关于个案概念化的书，以及这本书是怎么诞生的吗？好的，如我们所知，个案概念化是临床心理学家的核心技能，呃，我一直都在使用它，我接受过使用个案概念化的训练，就像所有心理学家一样。我可能没有对这个主题进行过太多的思考，直到我，呃，自己接受了临床心理学博士课程的一个职位，然后我就处于培训其他人使用
using formulation and it seemed to me that there was a big gap in the market. There were a few books out there and a few articles but actually considering this is meant to be our core professional skill there wasn't a lot of really in-depth thoughtful look at what formulation is, what it isn't, what its uses are, what its drawbacks are, what the controversies are, what the different perspectives of formulation might look like depending on which model you start with. So Rudy was working on the Plymouth course which was closely linked to the Bristol one and we put on a workshop, lots of people came along, it seemed to be a subject people are interested in.
个案概念化的位置上。在我看来，市场上存在一个很大的空白。当时有一些书和几篇文章，但实际上，鉴于这本该是我们的核心专业技能，却没有多少真正深入、深思熟虑的探讨来阐述什么是个案概念化、它不是什么、它的用途是什么、它的缺点是什么、其中的争议有哪些，以及根据你所采用的不同模型，个案概念化的不同视角可能是什么样的。当时鲁迪正在普利茅斯课程组工作，该课程与布里斯托尔的课程紧密相连，于是我们举办了一个研讨会，很多人都来了，这似乎是一个大家都很感兴趣的主题。
And out of that arose the book, which is now in its second edition. The first edition came out in 2000. The second edition came out in 2014. Well, I'm so thankful that you did. And for me, you were really one of the, you know, the trailblazers for clinical psychologists creating books as well. Certainly one of the first I was aware of and so you know you showed me that that we could and you know we've got something useful to say that we should so an extra thank you to that to you on that one as well but you know it's what I really like about the book and why our audience will find it particularly useful is that you you introduce you know vign't you, of case studies, and then
这本书就是在此基础上诞生的，现在已经出到第二版了。第一版于 2000 年出版。第二版于 2014 年出版。哦，我真是太感激你们写了这本书。对我来说，你真的是临床心理学家自己写书的先驱之一。绝对是我所知道的第一批先驱之一，所以你知道，你向我们展示了我们可以做到这一点，而且如果我们有有价值的观点要表达，我们就应该去表达。所以，在此我要对你表达额外的感谢。但是你知道，我真正喜欢这本书的地方，也是为什么我们的听众会觉得它特别有用的原因，在于你在书中引入了案例分析的
you formulate them from a variety of different perspectives throughout the book. So it's just really well done. Well, thank you. It was quite a lot of work. And there are a number of contributors. And as you say, the common thread of the book is we take two case histories which are based on real people. One is an adult man and the other is a child and her family. And the various chapters look at how we might formulate their difficulties from different perspectives. The standard ones, CBT, psychodynamic and so on, but also perhaps less common approaches like narrative therapy and
情境切片（vignettes），然后从书中各种不同的视角对它们进行个案概念化。所以这本书真的写得非常出色。谢谢。这确实花了不少功夫。书中有很多撰稿人。正如你所说，这本书的共同主线是，我们采用了两个基于真实人物的案例历史。一个是成年男性，另一个是一个儿童和她的家庭。各个章节探讨了我们如何从不同的视角来对他们的困难进行个案概念化。标准的有认知行为疗法（CBT）、心理动力学等等，但也包括一些不太常见的途径，比如叙事疗法和
social equalities approaches and so on. At the end there's a chapter about controversies and debates which I hope kind of ties the whole book up and leaves us thinking well you know we should have a critical perspective on anything everything that's always been what I believe so of course I'm broadly in favour of formulation. I've done done a lot of training it as well as practicing but I don't think we should be doing anything without thinking very carefully about what we're doing why we're doing it how it could be helpful but also how perhaps sometimes it can be unhelpful because you know there's no simple perfect answer to anyone's difficulties yeah absolutely and you know when when we share formulations with people and when we share um diagnoses with people we're absolutely thinking
社会平等途径等等。在最后有一章专门探讨争议与辩论，我希望这一章能将整本书串联起来，让我们觉得，好吧，我们应该对任何事情、所有事情都保持批判性的视角。这一直都是我的信念，所以当然，我总体上是支持个案概念化的。我在实践中以及培训中都大量运用过它，但我认为我们在做任何事情时，都必须非常仔细地思考我们在做什么、我们为什么这样做、它将如何发挥作用，但同时也要思考它有时可能会带来什么弊端，因为你知道，对于任何人的困难，都没有简单完美的答案。是的，绝对是这样。你知道，当我们与人们分享个案概念化时，当我们与人们分享
about it as being a way of understanding their difficulties but not necessarily defining them and you know them as a person yes although um as i've suggested in some cases i would hope we wouldn't be sharing diagnoses. And another theme of the book is really that psychologists have something much better to offer than the vast majority of psychiatric diagnoses. I mean, obviously, depending on which setting you work, there are valid diagnoses. If you're working in learning difficulties or in health settings, diagnoses may be appropriate and helpful. They are virtually never so in adult mental health settings. And so I very much want to promote formulation as something we can do instead
诊断结果时，我们绝对是将它们视为一种理解他们困难的方式，但并不一定是用这些来定义他们，定义他们作为人的本质。是的，尽管正如我所暗示的那样，在某些情况下，我希望我们不会去分享诊断结果。这本书的另一个主题其实是，心理学家能够提供比绝大多数精神病学诊断好得多的东西。我的意思是，很显然，取决于你在什么领域工作，有些诊断确实是有效的。如果你在学习困难（learning difficulties）或健康领域工作，诊断可能是恰当且有帮助的。但在成人心理健康领域，它们几乎从不适用。所以我非常希望能推广个案概念化，将其作为我们可以替代的做法，
and something that offers what diagnosis claims but fails to offer us, which is an evidence-based hypothesis and a way forward that can lead people out of services, we hope, rather than, as much too often happens, trap them within services, possibly for many decades. My work is in adult mental health as well. And so much of the work I do around developmental trauma is people really finding it very difficult and very uncomfortable and very painful to have gone through, you know, complex trauma, and then find themselves with diagnoses, which feel like an added insult to their injuries. You know, if they end up with a
它能提供诊断宣称能够提供但最终却未能提供给我们的东西——一种基于证据的假设，以及一条能够引导人们走出服务机构的道路，我们希望如此，而不是像经常发生的那样，把他们困在服务机构里，可能一困就是几十年。我的工作领域也是成人心理健康。我所做的许多围绕发展性创伤（developmental trauma）的工作中，很大一部分都是人们真的发现经历过复杂创伤（complex trauma）是一件非常艰难、非常不舒服、非常痛苦的事情，然后他们却发现自己被贴上了诊断标签，这让他们感觉是在伤口上撒盐。你知道，如果他们最终得到了一个
personality disorder diagnosis, they, you know, they Google that, and they feel like it doesn't describe me at all. And it Yeah, I think it's a useful conversation conversation to have I think it's an essential conversation to have and you know I absolutely think as psychologists we should routinely be having these conversations with people who will often come up along to us sort of pre-pre-labeled if you like they're told they have a diagnosis of some sort I mean a common diagnosis, as you say, particularly for women who may very frequently have a history of trauma is a so-called personality disorder of some sort. Now, I've always believed that people have the right to make up their own minds about how best to describe their difficulties, but I very strongly believe that that should be a kind of informed choice. And we should be letting
人格障碍（personality disorder）的诊断，他们就会去谷歌搜索，然后觉得这个诊断根本无法描述他们。这确实……是的，我认为这是一场值得进行的对话，我认为这是一场必不可少的对话。你知道，我绝对认为作为心理学家，我们应该例行公事般地与这些人进行这些对话，他们往往会带着某种“预先贴好的标签”来到我们面前，也就是说，有人告诉他们说他们患有某种诊断。我的意思是，正如你所说，一个常见的诊断——特别是对于那些很可能有着创伤史的女性来说——就是某种所谓的人格障碍。现在，我一直认为人们有权自己决定如何最好地描述他们的困难，但我坚信，这应该是一种知情选择。我们应该让
people know these are controversial labels they're not scientifically valid they you know even the people who draw up the diagnostic manuals are saying this these systems of categorization are neither safe nor scientifically sound that's a quote from the chair of the dsm4 committee you know it's it's not professionally acceptable for us not to inform people of that and of course they may need their diagnoses for some purposes they may actually feel it describes them quite well but very frequently people don't feel that and we can then obviously offer them a formulation based understanding instead but also as you suggest a trauma-informed understanding
人们知道，这些是有争议的标签，它们在科学上并不成立。你知道，甚至那些起草诊断手册的人都在说，这些分类系统既不安全，也不符合科学依据。这是 DSM-4 委员会主席的一句名言。你知道，如果我们不将这一点告知大众，在专业上是不可接受的。当然，为了某些目的，他们可能确实需要他们的诊断，他们甚至可能真的觉得这些诊断把他们描述得挺准的。但非常常见的情况是，人们并不这么觉得，于是我们显然可以转而为他们提供一种基于个案概念化的理解，同时也正如你所建议的，提供一种创伤知情（trauma-informed）的理解。
so more recently you know I've become very interested in trauma-informed understanding so more recently you know I've become very interested in trauma-informed approaches and I think all formulations need to be trauma-informed which of course doesn't mean that every person we meet has experienced what we might classically describe as a trauma but it means we need to be very very aware of the fact that that may well be the case and we need to incorporate that in aware of the fact that that may well be the case and we need to incorporate that in our formulating certainly but i don't know what your experiences are lucy but working in adult mental health people often tell me i don't know why i feel like this you know i feel like i've had a good enough childhood and you know i don't know it's probably
所以最近，你知道的，我对创伤知情的方法变得非常感兴趣。所以最近，你知道的，我对创伤知情的方法变得非常感兴趣，并且我认为所有的个案概念化都需要是创伤知情的。当然，这并不是说我们遇到的每个人都经历了我们传统意义上所描述的创伤，而是意味着我们需要非常非常清楚这样一个事实：这种情况完全是有可能的，我们需要将其纳入考量。当然，我们需要在个案概念化中将这一点纳入其中。露西，我不知道你的经历是怎样的，但在成人心理健康领域工作时，人们经常会对我说：“我不知道为什么我会有这种感觉，你知道，我觉得我的童年过得挺好，你知道，我不知道，这可能只是我自己的问题。”然后你实际上通过了解，
just me and then you actually go through you know key you know the ACE scale for example or thinking about developmental experiences and you realize and you help them appreciate that actually their needs and their difficulties can be understood within a diagnosis or a framework of complex trauma and that can be incredibly you know validating and empowering for them but also you, takes away a lot that guilt and that shame and that responsibility that they've been carrying for being the problem and it being their fault. Indeed. I mean, the trouble with a diagnostic label, it sort of locates the problem within the person, doesn't it? And a lot of psychological explanations do as well to be honest I mean I'm not just opposed to unscientific diagnostic categories but also to narrowly individualizing psychological ways of categorizing people
比如不良童年经历量表（ACE scale）的关键内容，或者思考他们的成长发育经历，你会意识到并帮助他们认识到，实际上他们的需求和困难可以在复杂创伤的诊断或框架内得到理解。这对于他们来说可以具有难以置信的肯定性和赋权作用，同时也能消除他们长期以来一直背负的许多内疚、羞耻感以及“问题出在自己身上、全都是自己的错”的责任感。确实如此。我的意思是，诊断标签的问题在于，它倾向于把问题定位在个人身上，对吧？说实话，很多心理学解释也是这样的。我的意思是，我不仅反对不科学的诊断类别，我也反对那种狭隘地将人们分类的个体化心理学方式。
essentially so as you say a lot of people will say and this may well be true I had a comfortable home and I had loving parents but things that can be experienced as traumatic can be a lot more subtle than that, of course. There can be more subtle forms of invalidation and emotional neglect, which we don't always identify as such. And also, we live in a difficult world, don't we? You know, I think there are many, many good reasons for really struggling, however fortunate we are in our families and our lives and young people I think particularly are facing horrendously difficult challenges nowadays I'm very glad I'm no longer young because I think it's a difficult world a very difficult world for young people to live in yeah I agree social media certainly adds new layers of difficulties and I found being a teenager
本质上讲，就像你说的，很多人会说——这完全可能是真的——“我有一个舒适的家，我也有慈爱的父母”。但当然，那些能被体验为创伤的事情要微妙得多。可能会有更微妙的形式的情感无效化（invalidation）和情感忽视，而我们并不总是能将它们识别为创伤。而且，我们生活在一个艰难的世界里，对吧？你知道，我认为无论我们在家庭和生活中多么幸运，都有很多很多充分的理由让我们感到生活挣扎。而且我认为现在的年轻人正面临着极其艰难的挑战。我很庆幸自己不再年轻了，因为我认为这是一个艰难的世界，一个对年轻人来说非常艰难的世界。是的，我同意。社交媒体无疑增加了新的困难层面，我发现自己当青少年的时候
difficult enough it's bad enough anyway yes think how much worse it is if you're also being bullied on social media you know and being told you ought to look like this have these kind of friendships live this kind of lifestyle all those kind of things and you know mental health social media is not always helpful either there's a I think a rather regrettable tendency for people nowadays to be self-diagnosing not even waiting to see a professional to google or look at a tiktok video that tells them they have something called adhd or autism spectrum disorder or whatever and to kind of find a sense of identity through that, which I can see the attraction of, but actually, I don't think that's necessarily in the long term, helpful. And,
已经够难熬的了。不管怎样，这已经够糟糕了。是的，想想看，如果你还要在社交媒体上遭受霸凌，那就更糟了。你知道，有人告诉你，你应该长成这样，要有这种类型的友谊，过这种类型的生活方式，所有这些类型的事情。而且，你知道，心理健康社交媒体也并非总是有帮助的。我认为现在的人们有一种相当令人遗憾的倾向，那就是进行自我诊断，甚至不等去看专业人士，就去谷歌搜索或者看一个 TikTok 视频，视频告诉他们自己患有一种叫做注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）或自闭症谱系障碍（autism spectrum disorder）之类的疾病，并试图通过这种方式找到一种认同感。我能理解这种吸引力的所在，但实际上，我认为从长远来看，这不一定是件好事。而且，
you know, we seem to be rapidly reaching the point where we're all going to be qualifying for a diagnosis of some sort. So that's one of the themes of the second edition of my book, A Straight Talking Introduction to Psychiatric Diagnosis, which came out just last week. First edition was 2014. And one of the trends that's increased very significantly since 2014 is the whole social media stuff. Both, I think, in terms of making all of us feel somehow less adequate and less okay about ourselves and in the form of offering kind of ways out in the terms of labeling ourselves which I think you know is a trend that we need to think about very carefully because I think it may well have more disadvantages than advantages. Yeah, absolutely. Congratulations on your newest book, Baby, for this year.
你知道，我们似乎正快速接近这样一个时刻：我们所有人都要符合某种诊断的标准了。所以这也是我的新书《直言不讳的精神病学诊断导论》（A Straight Talking Introduction to Psychiatric Diagnosis）第二版的主题之一，该书就在上周刚出版。第一版是 2014 年出的。自 2014 年以来显著增加的趋势之一就是整个社交媒体现象。我认为，这既表现在让我们所有人都觉得自己不知何故不够好、对自己感觉不太好，也表现在通过给我们自己贴标签来提供某种出路的形式上。我认为这是一个我们需要非常认真思考的趋势，因为我认为它带来的劣势很可能大于优势。是的，绝对的。恭喜你的新书今年问世。
Very recent this week. And I think, yeah, absolutely. We need to be careful about diagnosing ourselves and looking at labels. But I think for the general public, it's also really important to think about who is labelling themselves as something they may not be. So I often see people who might have done a psychology degree or, you know, counselling, calling themselves a psychologist publicly, and that can be really damaging and really dangerous. And part of my most recent media work
就在这周，非常新鲜。我认为，是的，绝对地，我们需要对自我诊断和关注标签保持谨慎。但对于大众来说，思考谁在给自己贴上他们可能并不具备的标签同样非常重要。所以我经常看到一些可能学过心理学学位或者咨询的人，公开称自己为心理学家，这可能会造成极大的破坏和危险。我最近的一些媒体工作的一部分，
is to try to encourage people to know what you might look for in a qualified therapist, a qualified psychologist. Well, there are plenty of bad psychologists and bad therapists out there I'm afraid yeah yeah I hear you um I have been asked a couple of questions from our aspiring psychologist audience for our formulation expert is there um a go-to formulation stance or approach that you'd recommend for people to kind of keep in their back pocket to pull out an interview or you know at any moment of pressure where they're asked for
就是试图鼓励人们去了解，在寻找合格的治疗师、合格的心理学家时，你应该寻找什么。嗯，恐怕外面有很多糟糕的心理学家和糟糕的治疗师。是的，是的，我听到了。呃，我们的有志心理学家听众向我们的个案概念化专家提出了几个问题。对于人们可以随身携带、在面试中或任何感到有压力的时刻拿出来应对的个案概念化立场或方法，你有什么推荐的“拿手绝活”或方法吗？现在正值面试季，对吧？所以会有很多人焦急地突击恶补：究竟什么是个案概念化？我的意思是，如果我们想要采取一点策略的话，大多数课程都会寻找某种对认知行为疗法（CBT）的意识和能力。我认为 CBT 有其优势，但我也认为它有一些局限性。不过我想，在这种情况下，可能重要的是不要将任何特定的模型抱得太紧，如果你懂我的意思的话。所以我们刚才讨论的那本书——《心理学与心理治疗中的个案概念化》（Formulation in Psychology and Psychotherapy），其中有一整章专门讲综合方法（integrative approaches）。我个人认为，除非我们的方法在某种程度上是综合的，否则我们几乎不可避免地会遗漏某些东西。
formulation? It's interview season at the moment isn't it so there's going to be lots of people anxiously swatting up what is a formulation I mean you know if we want to be a bit strategic about it most courses are going to be looking for some kind of awareness of and competence in CBT. And I think CBT has strengths and I think it has some limitations. But I guess it probably be important in that situation to any particular model held on to too closely, if you like. So the book that we've just talked about, Formulation in Psychology and Psychotherapy, has a whole chapter on integrative approaches. And I personally think we're almost inevitably going to be missing something unless our approach is to some extent integrative. So what the particular ingredients are of your own
所以，你自己的综合方法的具体成分是什么，将由你自己决定。但正如我之前已经说过的那样，我认为创伤知情（trauma-informed）的视角应该是其中之一。我的意思是，我发现自己从根本上是带着心理动力学（psychodynamic）的视角来的，我想，但其他人可能会有他们自己的偏好。事实上，在 2011 年，我是撰写英国心理学会临床心理学分会（Division of Clinical Psychology）关于使用心理个案概念化良好实践指南的小型核心专家组的主导作者。这已经是挺久以前的事了，但我认为它们依然非常相关。我们在这些指南中提到的一点是，心理学家在进行个案概念化时，确实需要从尽可能广泛的基础开始，即使在任何特定情况下，他们选择的是更狭隘、更具体的
integrative approach will be up to you. But as I've already said, I think a trauma-informed perspective should be one of them. And I mean, I see myself as coming fundamentally from a psychodynamic perspective, I guess, but other people might have their own preferences. And in fact, in 2011, I was the leader author in a small group of people who dropped the Division of Clinical Psychology, good practice guidelines on the use of psychological formulation. It's a while ago now, and I think they're still very relevant. And one of the things we said in those guidelines was that psychologists really need to be starting from as broad a base as they can in terms of their formulations, even if any particular situation, they choose a narrower or more specific
个案概念化或模型。我依然认为这是非常真实的。让我们尽可能广泛地思考，然后我们将处于更有利的地位来思考：我们的哪些工具、方法或视角对于这个特定的人会更有帮助。谢谢。这太有趣了。我真的是在和这个领域的专家对话。我很荣幸能请到你。我倾向于用家谱图（family tree）来开启我所做的任何评估或个案概念化，并试图了解人们的关系：谁还活着，谁不在了，你知道，关系的背景。这真的可以非常强大，非常具有启发性。这是我最初在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）中学到的东西，但时至今日，多年年年之后的今天，我仍然在这样做，它真的可以非常具有启发性。我认为这是一个非常好的切入点。你知道，有很多很好的切入点。这听起来对我有用的原因在于，它
formulation or model. And I still think that's very true. Let's think as widely as possible, then we'll be in a better position to think about, you know, which of our tools or approaches or perspectives is going to be more helpful for this particular person. Thank you. That's so interesting. And I really, really are speaking to the expert in this. I'm really honoured to have you here. I tend to start any assessment or formulation that I do with a family tree and trying to get an understanding of people's relationships, who's alive, who's not alive, you know, the context of relationships, it can be really, really powerful and really enlightening. And it's something I first learned in a CAMHS service, but I still do it now, you know, years and years and years later, it can be really enlightening. I think that's a very good place to start. You know, there are a number of good places to start. And the way the reason that sounds useful to me is because it's
从一开始就从语境（context）入手，不是吗？这样你就不太可能会得出一个以无益的方式过度个体化的结论。是的。“为什么是现在？”这个问题也是……“为什么是现在？”，确实如此。是什么引发了它——用专业术语来说，诱因（triggers）几乎总是意义重大，因为它们几乎总是代表了关于一个人的生活以及他们挣扎的更广泛或更复杂得多的东西。所以，为什么是现在？你有什么样的理解？你可能遇到过什么样的诊断性理解？我们要谈谈这个吗？你的目标是什么？但我的意思是，个案概念化的核心在于意义（meaning）。它是关于
immediately starting from the context, isn't it? It's going to be, you're going to be less likely to come up with something that's perhaps more individualising in an unhelpful way. Yeah. And the question why now is also... Why now, indeed. What started it, the trigger in the jargon terms triggers are nearly always significant because they nearly always stand for something much broader or much more complex about a person's life and their struggles so why now what understandings do you have what diagnostic understandings may have come across shall we talk about that what are your goals but i mean centrally formulation is about meaning it's about
共同构建意义。因此，在临床心理学分会（DCP）关于个案概念化的指南中，我们将这一点作为了一条非常重要的主线：个案概念化本质上是关于共同构建意义的，而意义正是将你要讨论的个案概念化的任何其他方面整合在一起的主线。这就是为什么我们在指南中对一些更流行的个案概念化类型有所保留，比如“五个 P”（5 Ps）。我自己其实不是“五个 P”的超级粉丝，因为麻烦在于，它最后可能只变成了一张因素列表：这件事发生了，那件事发生了，这又发生了……我认为这是个案概念化之前的阶段。我认为真正的个案概念化，是你展示所有这些事情是如何联系在一起的，而将它们串联在一起的主线，
co-constructing meaning so in the we've used this very much a thread in the dcp guidelines and formulation the idea that essentially what a formulation is is about co-constructing meaning and meaning is the thread that integrates whatever other aspects of the formulation you're going to be discussing which is why we have some reservations in the guidelines about some of the more popular types of formulation out the five p's i'm not a big fan of the five p's myself because the trouble is it can just end up the list of factors this happened this happened this happened and i think that's the stage before a formulation. I think an actual formulation is when you show how all these things hang together and the thread on which they hang
就是你对它们所赋予的意义。所以，我最喜欢的个案概念化定义之一是：持续的协作意义构建过程（an ongoing process of collaborative meaning making）。从某种意义上说，这描述了整个治疗过程，但它也描述了治疗中的一个特定部分，你可能在某个时刻选择将其总结、写下来或分享出来，这就是我们所说的个案概念化。是的，我想到了你的，呃，纵向个案概念化（longitudinal formulation）——我想它在你的书里占了整整一页——它真的是黄金标准，我无法告诉你我花了多少小时去研究它，试图复制它，并在我自己的学习过程中把它应用到我的来访者身上。它真的非常有用，还有你的那些三角形——等一下，我觉得那不是我个人的东西，那是另一个作者写的。好吧，它真的很有用，还有你的三角形也是，它们救了我……
together is the meaning that you've made of them. And so one of my favourite definitions of formulation is an ongoing process of collaborative meaning making, which in a way describes therapy as a whole but it also describes a particular part of therapy which you might at some point choose to summarize or write down or share which is what we call a formulation yeah i think of your um longitudinal formulation which i think takes up a whole page in your book as being really gold standard and I can't tell you the hours I spent studying that and trying to replicate that and bolt that on for my clients during my own studies it's just honestly really useful and your triangles don't think that was mine personally that was some that was another author well it's really useful and your try your triangles as well you know they save me
对，对，三角形确实很好。但我的意思是，有很多方法可以做到这一点。我想说的另一件事是，我认为我们不想把这变成一个听起来太吓人的技能，因为实际上我们都是人类，这是我们自然而然就会做的事情：我们构建意义，你知道，我们试图去理解我们的生活。这是一种特定的做事方式，但我可不希望给人留下这样一种印象或传递这样一种信息：只有心理学家才能做到这一点。许多专业人士都能做到这一点，事实上，个案概念化正在进入许多不同职业的核心能力中，而且人类本身就会这样做——我们的妈妈、我们的朋友，或者你知道的，作家、小说家，在更广阔的意义上也可以是非常熟练的个案概念化者。所以它是一种具有特定用途的独特视角，
yeah yeah triangles are good but i mean there are lots of ways of doing it and one of the other things i like to say is that i don't think we want to make this into too scary sounding a skill because actually we're all human beings this is something we do automatically we make meaning you know we try to make sense of our lives it's a particular way of doing things but i wouldn't want to think or to be giving the message that only psychologists can do this lots of professionals can do this and indeed formulation is finding its way into the core competencies of a number of different professions and human beings do it you know our mums or our friends or you know authors novelists may also be in a broader sense very skilled formulators so it's a particular take which has particular uses
我认为它既是一项专业服务中的技能，也是一项普遍的（人类技能）。绝对是这样。我想也许这个词把人们吓退了。我想也许这个词把人们吓退了。我想也许这个词——是的，它确实把人们吓退了。是的，就像“这有个极其高档的东西，我必须在这方面非常擅长”。但是作为一个有志心理学家，可能发生在我身上的最尴尬的事情之一，就是当我们在病房查房（ward round）时，精神科医生突然转向我问：“那么，你对这个病例的个案概念化是什么？”然后现场就会陷入一片死寂，就像滚草球吹过一样。但你知道，如果他们能换成问：“你对为什么会发生这种情况以及为什么现在发生有什么理解？”那其实就是它的全部含义，真的。是的，你知道，我经常说的一件事是，个案概念化并不是某种你必须在查房时、在你的病历中或任何给定时刻
in service I think on a general you know human skill absolutely and I think maybe the word scares people off I think one of the maybe the word scares people off i think one of the yeah it does scare people off yeah like here's something terribly fancy that i've got to be very good at but one of the most mortifying things that could happen to me um as an aspiring psychologist was when we were in ward round and the psychiatrist would turn to me and say well what's your formulation on this and then they're just like tumbleweed moment but you know if they've been able to say what's your understanding of why this is happening now and why well that's all it means really yeah and you know one of the things that i always say is that formulation isn't a thing that you have to
完美产出或构思周全的东西。它是一个过程。我们在指南中讨论过这一点：区分“作为事件的个案概念化”（这是你可能在课程中遇到它的方式：你把它写下来，提交上去，上面批满了涂鸦，然后你重新提交，或者也许不用，也许你第一次就写得很棒）与“作为过程的个案概念化”。因为实际上，那个事件只是正在进行的讨论过程的一个快照，会议总是在不断演变。当我在接受培训时，我会鼓励实习学员甚至在见到当事人之前就开始进行个案概念化：你会从病历记录
produce or perfectly worked out at any given moment in a ward round or in your notes or whatever it's an it's it's a process really we've discussed this in the guidelines the distinction between formulation as an event which is how you probably encounter on a course you write it down you submit it it comes back with scribbles all over it you resubmit it or perhaps you don't perhaps it was very good first time around and formulation as a process because really that event is only a snapshot of an ongoing discussion process really, and meetings are always evolving. And when I was in training, I would be encouraging the trainees to be formulating in a sense before you even meet the person, you will have some kind of information from the notes
或转诊信中获得某种信息。当然，你必须对这些信息持暂定的态度，它可能是错的。而且很多时候它与实际情况大相径庭。但尽管如此，它依然是一个起点，你和他们的理解在不断演变、持续发展，并且始终对反思和改变保持开放。绝对的。这确实是我在第五个实习期学到的东西，实际上就是做好准备，在第一天几乎就要带着读过档案后自己对个案概念化的初步想法，去参加我的第一次督导会议。在当时这让我感到有点可怕，但实际上，你知道，这是一种真正有用的方式，让我们能够以建设性的方式利用那些阅读时间。
or referral. And obviously, you have to hold that tentatively, it might be wrong. And quite often often it's way off the mark but nevertheless it's a starting point and your understandings and their understandings you know evolve and continue and are always open to kind of reflection and change definitely that's certainly something that I learned to do during my fifth placement actually was to come ready prepared to my first supervision session with my on almost on day one having read the files and come up with my own sort of idea of formulations which at the time felt a bit horrifying but actually is you know a real
是的，你的第一个个案概念化将会是非常暂定的，它可能只是一句话：“听起来你早年生活发生了一些困难的事情，而最近的事件把其中一些事情带到了表面上来。”我的意思是，在心理健康领域，当某人首次求诊时，这是一个几乎适用于所有情况的个案概念化。或者我有时在培训中会说，你知道，“在依附困难背景下的创伤”将涵盖绝大多数心理健康客户。并非所有人都是如此，但作为一种“我想知道这是否是一个切入个案概念化的好地方”，这绝对不是一个切入个案概念化的坏地方。那绝对不是一个切入个案概念化的坏地方。当然，我很感兴趣，你如何看待最近从更多的临床工作中抽身出来之后的感受？你如何
useful way for us using that reading reading time um in a constructive way yeah and your first formulation is going to be very tentative and it might be a sentence you know it sounds like some difficult things happened earlier on in your life and recent events have brought some of those to the surface i mean that's that's a, nearly all-purpose formulation in mental health for when someone first presents. Or I sometimes say in training, you know, trauma in the context of attachment difficulties will cover vast numbers of mental health clients. Not all of them, but as a kind of, I wonder if this is a place to start formulation. That's not a bad place to start formulation that's that's not a bad place to start absolutely how i'm interested how are you finding having stepped away from more clinical work recently how are you
适应这种转变？嗯，这感觉挺不一样的。我想念临床工作，我的确想念临床工作。但我抽身而出的原因是为了做一件相当不同的事情，那就是，呃，首先是完成“权力-威胁-意义框架”（Power Threat Meaning Framework，PTMF），这是一个非常非常有野心的项目，旨在为痛苦的诊断模型勾勒出一个概念上的替代方案。我是主要作者之一，另一位是玛丽·博伊尔教授（Professor Mary Boyle），她也是一位心理学家。这个项目由一群心理学家、服务使用者和幸存者共同创作，他们彼此相识多年，并得到了临床心理学分会的资助。我们当时着手进行这项疯狂雄心勃勃的任务，不仅要思考我们如何用个案概念化来代替诊断，比如说，或者我们如何用创伤知情
adjusting to that well it's it's kind of different i miss clinical work i do miss clinical work but the reason i stepped away is to do something rather different which was to um well first of all to finish the power threat meaning framework which is this very very ambitious project to outline a conceptual alternative the diagnostic model of distress uh i'm the one of the lead authors along with professor mary boyle who's another psychologist and it's co-produced by a group of psychologists and service users, survivors, all of whom have known each other for many years, funded by the Division of Clinical Psychology. And we were embarked on this ludicrously ambitious task to think about not just how can we use formulation instead of diagnosis, let's say, or how can we use trauma-informed
实践来代替医疗模型实践，而且还要思考：诊断模型的一个完整概念替代方案会是什么样的？从医疗模型的理解迈出巨大飞跃，转向……嗯，转向什么？这就是我们给自己设定的任务。识别痛苦模式的截然不同方式会是什么样子？所以，五年后，我们带着这份庞大的文件出现了。我想你会在聊天中提供指向该网站的链接。我放弃临床工作的原因是，我和玛丽最终都不得不几乎花了两年时间坐在电脑前，确保这个该死的东西达到准备好出版的阶段。自那以后，它出乎意料地成了我的全职工作，所以我围绕“权力-威胁-意义框架”做了
practice instead of medical model practice, but what would a complete conceptual alternative, the diagnostic model, look like? What would it look like to make the giant leap away from medical model understandings towards, well, towards what? That was the task we set ourselves. What would a very different way of identifying patterns of distress look like. So we, five years later, we emerged with this massive document. I think you're going to supply the links in the chat to the website. And the reason I gave up clinical work was because I and Mary both in the end had to spend virtually two years sitting in front of our computers and actually making sure this damn thing was reached a stage where it's ready to be published and since then it's quite unexpected to become my job so I do
大量的培训、写作、旅行、演讲、播客以及各种各样的事情。所以，你知道，我想念临床工作，但我找到了可以替代它的东西，这与它有某种关联，而且实际上同样重要。在某些我职业生涯中所做思考的层面上，它总结了我职业生涯中所有的思考。参与这个项目的其他人也是如此。这听起来太迷人了。当然，等这期节目上线后，我们会在节目文案中放置任何链接，以便人们能够访问这个真正，呃，真正有用且具有开创性的东西。你知道，现在正是一个激动人心的时刻，
a lot of training and writing and traveling and talking and podcasts and all sorts of things in relation to the power threat meaning framework so you know I've missed clinical work and I found something to replace it which is kind of related and equally important, actually. And in some ways, it summarises all the thinking I've done throughout my career. And the same is true, I think, of the other people who are involved in the project. It sounds like fascinating stuff. And absolutely, when this goes live, we'll pop any links in the show notes so that people can access this really um really useful and there's like seminal seminal stuff you know it's it's an exciting time um to be to be putting that out there um is there any other advice that you would offer for aspiring psychologists um
能把这些东西推向大众。对于有志成为心理学家的人，你还有什么其他的建议吗？嗯，首先，你知道，临床心理学并不是唯一的出路。要考上这个专业很难。如果你没有考上，还有其他选择。你完全可以通过不同的职业道路，以非常相似的方式从事相关工作。你知道，我认为这是一条很棒的职业路径，但我发现人们往往过分执着于“我必须这样做”。这种执着带来的悖论效应之一就是，当你真的考入这个专业后，却发现它并非完美无缺，这会让你感到相当沮丧和失望。所以，要抱有现实的期望。还有其他选择。我认为
well first of all i mean you know clinical psychology isn't the be all and end all. It's hard to get on a course. If you don't, there are other options. You could end up working in a very similar way from some different career path. You know, I think it's a great career path, but I think people are very fixated on this is what I must do. And one of the paradoxical effects of that is when you get onto a course and find it's not perfect, it can feel quite frustrating and disappointing. You know, so realistic expectations. There are other options. I think I think the other thing I would say is, I mean, critical thinking is so important, which is, again, something I've always believed. So you will have to read and believe and study and say certain things in order to get onto a course, in order to do your psychology degree in the first place. A lot of it, in my
我想说的另一件事是，批判性思维是如此重要，这同样是我一直以来的信念。因此，为了考入这个专业，为了首先完成你的心理学学位，你将不得不阅读、相信、学习并说出某些特定的事情。其中很大一部分，我
view, is completely wrong. Possibly most of it. I'd have fundamental disagreements with a lot of the core tenets of clinical psychology practice. So really, really, really don't necessarily believe what you're told. Think about it, explore alternatives, you know, develop your own style, your own beliefs, question everything you've been told. It's all up for grabs, really. We are at quite an exciting time, I think, in what we call mental health. It's not a term I like, actually, but the experiences we call mental health and how we understand them. We are at a point of very rapidly shifting understandings, which is great. But that means really being able to challenge ourselves and things that we've always thought and believe without question. So questioning everything is uncomfortable, but I think in the end it gets you to a better and more interesting place.
这种看法完全是错误的。可能大部分都是错的。我对临床心理学实践的很多核心信条持有根本性的分歧。所以真的、真的、真的不要盲目相信别人告诉你的东西。去思考它，去探索替代方案，你知道的，培养你自己的风格，你自己的信念，去质疑你被告知的一切。这其实都是可以讨论的。我认为，在我们所说的心理健康领域，这是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻。其实我并不喜欢“心理健康”这个词，但我们所经历的被称为心理健康的东西以及我们如何理解它们。我们正处于一个理解方式迅速转变的节点，这太棒了。但这确实意味着我们要能够挑战自我，挑战那些我们一直以来不加质疑的想法和信念。所以，质疑一切是让人感到不舒服的，但我认为最终它会引导你走向一个更好、更有趣的境地。
Yeah, and it certainly can facilitate more strategic conversations can't it which is yeah you know we're good at rattling cages um in the psychology profession well some of us are some of us are some of us a bit too happy not to rattle cages in my view i think what i see as as people are progressing through their routes towards becoming, you know, trainee psychologist or whatever, whatever type of psychologist they want to become is something alluding to what you've said there, is that they become more, yeah, more confident in their own way of seeing the world and are less, you know, less affected or less asking or less striving for input from others. And they just feel ready to hold their head up at interview and say well this is how I see the world this is how I understand it
是的，它确实可以促进更具战略性的对话，不是吗？在心理学界，我们确实擅长打破常规，嗯，我们中的一些人是这样的，我们中的一些人……在我的看法中，我们中有的人甚至对不打破常规感到太高兴了。我认为我看到的是，随着人们在成为心理学实习生或无论他们想成为什么类型的心理学家的道路上不断前进时，有些事情暗示了你刚才所说的，那就是他们变得更加自信了，用他们自己的方式看待世界，受他人的影响更少，或者更少去请求、更少去努力寻求他人的输入。他们只是觉得在面试时可以昂首挺胸地说，好吧，这就是我看待世界的方式，这就是我理解它的方式
using this that approaches but this is my take on it and I think that's really powerful yeah yeah it is it is and the framework I hope gives people quite a lot of leeway to think about how they might want to understand their work, you know, the assumptions behind their work, the difficulties people come up present with, because it's a set of ideas, it's really not a sort of how-to manual, it's about as far as the ways you can possibly get from let's say a stereotypical, you know, IAPT-based, really rigid manualised approach, which I have to say I'm not in favour of. Right. The other end of that spectrum is something like the framework. And the message really is look at these ideas and think about how they might make use to you, how they might be useful to you.
用这种方法，但这是我的看法，我认为这非常强大。是的，是的，确实如此，我希望这个框架能给人们相当大的余地，去思考他们可能如何想要理解他们的工作，你知道的，他们工作背后的假设，人们所呈现的困难，因为它是一套理念，它真的不像那种操作手册，它与那种刻板的、基于IAPT的、非常僵化的套路化方法大相径庭，而我必须说，我并不赞成这种方法。对的。光谱的另一端就像这个框架一样。而真正的信息是：看看这些想法，思考它们如何对你有所帮助，如何能对你发挥作用。
And one of the things we've done in the framework is to try and move beyond formulation as such. So formulation, I think, as I said, is an extraordinarily useful tool within services. We've deliberately used the term narrative in the Power Threat Meaning Framework because it is, broadly speaking, a narrative-based approach. The simple answer to what to do instead of diagnosis in framework terms is we use narrative-based understandings but if we broaden the narrative to include art, music, poetry, dance, you know community rituals, legends, understandings then we can include a whole range of ways of understanding a human distress which historically have always been around which cross-culturally still are around and validate all of those as well without needing to package in package it in you know actually very westernized narrow westernized way as psychology
我们在框架中所做的事情之一，就是试图超越单纯的建构方案（formulation）。因此，正如我所说，建构方案是服务中一个非常非常有用的工具。我们在“权力-威胁-意义框架”中刻意使用了“叙事”这个词，因为它广义上说是一种基于叙事的方法。用框架的术语来说，代替诊断该做什么的简单答案是，我们使用基于叙事的理解，但如果我们拓宽叙事，将艺术、音乐、诗歌、舞蹈、你知道的，社区仪式、传说、理解都包含在内，那么我们就可以包容一系列理解人类痛苦的方式。这些方式历史上一直存在，跨文化中也依然存在，并且所有这些都可以得到认可，而不需要把它们打包成实际上非常西方化的、狭隘的西方心理学形式
or psychotherapy or psychiatry so that allows us i think to accommodate and learn from and work much more comfortably alongside non-westernized understandings of distress without feeling the need to colonize them with our own psychiatric categories or psychological categories. In both cases, those may be inappropriate. So when I presented the framework recently, actually to a group of third-year clinical psychologists and trainees, one of them said to me, so how would I use the framework in this setting that I'm hoping to work in? So I said, well, you can use it how you like. We don't have the answer. Try it out. Let us know. Write it up if it seems to work. This will contribute further
或者是心理治疗，或者是精神病学。所以，我认为这使我们能够包容、借鉴并更舒适地与非西方对痛苦的理解并肩工作，而不必觉得需要用我们自己的精神病学类别或心理学类别去对它们进行殖民。在这两种情况下，这些类别可能都是不恰当的。因此，当我最近向一群三年级临床心理学家和实习生介绍这个框架时，其中一个人对我说：“那么，在我希望工作的这个环境中，我将如何使用这个框架呢？”于是我说：“好吧，你想怎么用就怎么用。我们没有答案。去试试吧。让我们知道。如果觉得管用就把它写下来。这将为框架做进一步的贡献”
to the framework. So this trainee said, that's extraordinary. You mean I'm allowed to do how I like. I don't have to come up with, you know, some massively detailed according to the manual version. That's so refreshing. And I found that comment a little bit depressing, actually, because really, you know, to be steered into, you know, expert driven, narrow, manualised ways of thinking at quite an early stage of your career and being told you have to do it this way is not a helpful starting point I think. I think there's definitely some overlap there with you know what we're doing to our aspiring psychologists on the way up especially in services where there's high demand and lots and lots of client hours in an IAPT service for example you know our aspiring
所以这位实习生说：“太不可思议了。你是说我可以按我喜欢的方式做？我不必按照手册做出一大堆极其详细的版本。这太令人耳目一新了。”实际上，我觉得这个评论有点令人沮丧，因为说实话，在职业生涯的早期就被引导进入由专家主导的、狭隘的、照本宣科的思维方式，并被告知你必须这样做，我认为这不是一个有帮助的起点。我认为这与我们在上升期对待有抱负的心理学家的做法肯定有一些重叠，特别是在那些需求量很大、客户小时数非常多的机构中，比如在IAPT服务中，你知道的，我们有抱负的
psychologists are burning out. They're feeling disillusioned. They're not being well supported. And that's a separate conversation, but it's really important. Well, it's kind of it's kind of related because that comes out of a particular, I would say, ideological strand of clinical psychology, doesn't it? That these very narrow versions of CBT, you know, which is not CBD practice as a whole, are somehow more evidence-based, whatever that means, and we've deconstructed that term in the framework, what counts as evidence,
心理学家正在精疲力竭。他们感到幻灭。他们没有得到很好的支持。这是一个独立的话题，但它非常重要。嗯，这有点，这有点相关，因为那来自于临床心理学的一个特定的、我要说是意识形态的分支，不是吗？这些非常狭隘的CBT版本（你知道的，这并不是整体上的CBD实践），不知何故被认为更具循证基础——不管这意味着什么，我们在框架中解构了这个术语——什么算作证据，
who decides, who benefits from it, whose voices are excluded and silenced by it, and so on. And actually, IAPT is not producing good outcomes. Well, I don't think that's surprising, and I think it can be as you say quite a damaging experience for those who are persuaded they need to they have to offer a kind of assembly line version of this intervention for this narrowly defined problem yeah people are saying to me and i'm sort of here now but i don't even know if I want to do this now. Yeah, that's a shame. I mean, and that's worrying. And it's part of a bigger and also very worrying trend.
谁来决定，谁从中受益，谁的声音被它排除和压制，等等。事实上，IAPT并没有产生好的结果。嗯，我认为这并不令人意外，而且正如你所说，对于那些被说服认为他们需要、必须为这种狭隘定义的问题提供某种流水线式的干预的人来说，这可能是一种相当具有破坏性的经历。是的，人们对我说，我现在有点这样，但我甚至不知道我现在是否还想做这个。是的，那太遗憾了。我的意思是，这令人担忧。而且这是一个更大且同样令人担忧的趋势的一部分。
Well, you know, I think it's about individualising distress, to be honest. People who turn up at IAP services have very good reasons to distress, which very often have much broader roots than their negative thinking, or whatever it is you're supposed to target. That's, you you know so actually we're missing the main point often absolutely have you got any advice that you wish you'd been told or that you'd give to your younger self lucy um don't work so hard it's too late for that i'm a bit of a workaholic and uh I mean this is a more personal thing you
嗯，你知道的，老实说，我认为这是关于将痛苦个体化。那些出现在IAPT服务中的人有非常充分的痛苦理由，而这些理由通常比他们的消极思维或其他你本应作为目标的所谓根源要广泛得多。那就是，你知道的，所以实际上我们往往错过了重点。绝对的。你有什么希望自己当初被告知，或者希望给年轻时的自己的建议吗，露西？嗯，不要工作得太累。现在说这个太晚了，我有点工作狂，而且……我的意思是，这是一个更私人的事情，你
know I I wish I'd gone half time when my kids were young and so on life was quite stressful but I mean otherwise I've always been very pleased I've had the career I've had I think it suited me really well and you know of course there are things I wish I'd learned sooner or done differently but I mean that's that's part of the process, isn't it? I think at any point of our lives, and especially when we're working with clients as well, doing a bit of a joy audit can be really useful. Looking at where we're getting joyful or enjoyable experiences. And, you know, that's certainly something that I hold on to. It's really important. You know, if we're all work and no play then it's not
知道，我希望当年我孩子还小的时候我能选择做兼职等等，生活压力挺大的。不过除此之外，我一直很高兴我拥有过这样的职业生涯，我觉得它非常适合我。而且，你知道，当然有些事情我希望自己能早点学到或者做得不一样，但我的意思是，这也是过程的一部分，不是吗？我认为在我们生活的任何阶段，特别是当我们也在与客户一起工作时，做一个小小的“快乐审计”（joy audit）会非常有用。看看我们在哪里获得了快乐或愉快的体验。而且，你知道，这绝对是我所坚持的东西。这真的很重要。你知道，如果我们只有工作而没有娱乐，那么它就
it doesn't feel much fun indeed and you know i've had an awful lot of fun and joy through my work but actually i probably at times got that out of balance with the rest of my life is there anything that you wish i'd asked you that we haven't i think we've covered most things to be honest and i think we've covered most things and as you say there are we'll put some links for anyone who wants to follow up any of these thoughts or ideas i certainly will where can people get hold of copies of your books lucy um i've sent you some links so i mean they're available on the places, the rather unethical places that we tend to go to because they're just easy and cheap and quick. But several of my two most recent books, the one on the power threat meaning framework with Mary Boyle and the second edition of the book on diagnosis are available through PCCS books, actually more cheaply than on Amazon.
不会感觉很有趣，确实，而且我在工作中也获得了很多的乐趣和快乐，但实际上我有时可能把这与生活的其他部分搞得失去了平衡。有没有什么你希望我问但我们还没问的？说实话，我觉得我们已经涵盖了大部分事情，我想我们已经涵盖了大部分事情，正如你所说，对于任何想要跟进这些想法或理念的人，我们会提供一些链接，我肯定会的。人们可以在哪里买到你的书，露西？嗯，我给你发了一些链接，所以我的意思是它们可以在那些地方买到——那些我们倾向于去的不太道德的地方，因为它们就是简单、便宜又快捷。但是我的两本最新书，一本是与玛丽·博伊尔（Mary Boyle）合著的关于“权力-威胁-意义框架”的书，另一本是关于诊断学的书的第二版，都可以通过PCCS出版社买到，其实比在亚马逊上买还要便宜。
Very good advice. I'll make sure that I pop the links to that in in the show notes but honestly Marianne who was in her mid early to mid-20s meeting you today at 40 I just you know I feel incredibly lucky and to have held your book in my hands and it's shaped my career and now go on to shape other people's careers you know thank you from me to you for all the other aspiring and qualified psychologists across the land and the world um you know what you what you have done really matters and it's really helped us shape things with with our clients as well people you'll never meet but your work has touched them and benefited them. Well, that's lovely to hear. Thank you. Sorry, it's taken 15 years for us to meet. Thank you. And good luck to everyone watching.
非常好的建议。我一定会在节目简介中附上相关的链接。但老实说，玛丽安（Marian），当年那个20岁出头、今天在40岁时与你相遇的女孩，我只是，你知道，我感到不可思议地幸运，能将你的书捧在手中，它塑造了我的职业生涯，现在又去塑造其他人的职业生涯，你知道的，请允许我代表全国乃至全世界所有有抱负的和合资格的心理学家向你表示感谢，嗯，你知道，你所做的事情真的很重要，它也确实帮助我们塑造了与客户的关系，那些你永远不会见但你的工作触及并使之受益的人。哦，听到这话真高兴。谢谢。对不起，我们花了15年才见面。谢谢。祝所有观看的人好运。
I should have asked sooner. If you should. But thank you very much. And you're everything I hoped you would be. And, yeah, I will, you know, look forward to connecting with you in future. And I will definitely get hold of a copy of your book. Thank thank you so much for listening and thank you to our guest Dr Lucy Johnston for so generously giving us her time to think about these very important issues and I hope that you will find it thought-provoking and it will resonate with you as I record this there are spaces available on the aspiringpiring Psychologist membership.
我应该早点问的。如果你应该的话。非常感谢。你就是我所希望的一切。而且，是的，你知道的，我期待着在未来与你联系。我一定会去买一本你的书。非常感谢您的收听，也要感谢我们的嘉宾露西·约翰逊博士（Dr. Lucy Johnston）慷慨地抽出时间与我们一起思考这些非常重要的问题，我希望你会觉得这引人深思并且能引起你的共鸣。在我录制这段音频时，“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）还有名额。
If you'd like any information on how to join the membership and how to be part of my world, then please do check out my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, which you can grab in the show notes or via any of my socials. Depending on when you're listening to this, we have the final planned Compassionate Q&A to support people during this tricky application and interview season. So it is scheduled to take place on Monday the 9th of May at 7.30pm UK time. And that will be happening across all of my socials and streaming simultaneously. So if you have an interview or you know someone that does, then do direct them that way. You can also watch on replay. And you can also watch all of the previous Q&As that I have
如果你想要任何关于如何加入会员以及如何成为我世界一部分的信息，那么请查看我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），你可以在节目简介中获取，或者通过我的任何社交媒体找到。根据你收听这段节目的时间，我们有计划中的最后一次“同理心问答”（Compassionate Q&A），旨在在这个棘手的申请和面试季为人们提供支持。它定于英国时间5月9日星期一晚上7点30分举行。这将在我所有的社交媒体上同时进行流媒体直播。所以如果你有面试或者你知道有人有面试，请引导他们去那个方向。你也可以观看回放。你还可以观看我之前做过的
done by heading to my link tree, there's a playlist there. Or alternately, you can go straight to the Good Thinking Psychological Services, YouTube page, and check out the playlist there, which is for Q&As for aspiring psychologists. All right, I think that is all of our bits and pieces covered for today. If you would like to leave any sort of audio testimonial for the podcast or any of the other content that I'm involved in, I would be thrilled to include it within the podcast episodes. Thank you for being part of my world. Stay kind to yourselves and I will catch you very soon. Take care. This podcast is not your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner.
所有的问答，只需前往我的Linktree，那里有一个播放列表。或者，你也可以直接访问“美好心理学服务”（Good Thinking Psychological Services）的YouTube页面，查看专为有抱负的心理学家准备的问答播放列表。好了，我想这就是我们今天涵盖的所有零碎内容了。如果你想为播客或我参与的任何其他内容留下任何形式的音频评价，我将非常高兴把它收录到播客节目中。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。对彼此好一点，我们很快就会再聊。保重。这个播客不是你的副业，它将助你走上成为合资格专家的道路。这里是由玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）主持的“有抱负的心理学家播客”。我叫亚娜（Yana），是一名心理健康实习从业人员。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。达到这个目标竟然有这么多不同的途径，而且没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我感到十分惊奇。这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，觉得不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下了。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。